Can you construct an equilateral triangle
from a line segment AB?
Think about
how you can do it?
To construct the equilateral triangle, we
have to find the third vertex other
than ‘A’ and ‘B’.
For that, let’s take a compass.
We put the fixed point of compass on one of
the
points, say ‘B’.
Now taking this line segment ‘AB’ as the
radius, we draw a circle
with ‘B’ as its centre.
Similarly, without changing the length of
the compass,
repeat the process by placing its fixed point
on point ‘A’.
Now we see that we
have two circles with centres ‘A’ and
‘B’ and both these circles intersect at
these 2 points.
So if we join points ‘A’ and ‘B’ to
this point, we see that they are
nothing but the radii of the circles.
And since the radii of both the circles are
equal to each other and also equal to the
length of side AB, we get an
equilateral triangle here.
We will get an equilateral triangle even if
we join
points A and B to this point here.
Wasn’t it interesting?
Such knowledge of geometry was known to people
from ancient times…
Around 300 B.C.E, the Greek mathematician
Euclid combined all the
knowledge of geometry known at that time in
a set of 13 books called
Elements.
One interesting thing Euclid did was that
he set out to prove that the
geometrical relations known at that time follows
logically from some simple
things we know intuitively to be true.
Euclid showed that the knowledge of
geometry can be proven by just assuming some
things to be true.
These five true statements form the base of
all modern geometry.
He called
these true statements or facts as POSTULATES.
You’d be wondering what the
difference between axioms and postulates is!
Well in Geometry, they are
essentially interchangeable.
The general meaning of a postulate is a true
statement.
But in case of Euclid, a
postulate is a true statement or rather a
fact that is applicable in geometry
only.
So in this lesson, let us take a look at the
five important postulates that
Euclid devised which helped him prove more
theorems.
Let’s have a look at what the first postulate
says:
It states that “A straight line may be drawn
from any one point to any other
point.”
To understand this, suppose we have two points
‘A’ and ‘B’ separated by a
distance.
Now if we want to join them, we see that we
can draw only one
straight line that will connect the both of
them.
We can take help of Euclid’s
axiom that states “Given two distinct points,
there is a unique line passing
through them”.
So a line from ‘A’ joining ‘B’, is
‘A B’.
Similarly, the line joining ‘A’ from ‘B’
is
also ‘A B’.
**
The second postulate states that “A terminated
line can be produced
indefinitely”
By ‘terminated line’, we understand that
it is a line segment.
This postulate
means that if we have line segment ‘A B’,
we can extend both of its ends
endlessly.
What about the next postulate?
**
The third postulate says that “A circle
can be drawn with any centre and any
radius”.
This postulate is self-explanatory, but for
our understanding let’s assume a line
segment ‘A B’.
Keep point ‘A’ fixed and move point ‘B’
around point ‘A’.
We will
see that it will make a circle, and the length
of the line segment ‘A B’ will be
the radius of the circle.
Likewise, we can draw a circle from any point
and with
any radius.
**
The fourth postulate says that “All right
angles are equal to one another”.
Look at a square and a rectangle.
We see that all the interior angles of the
rectangle and square are right angles!
Therefore, an angle from a square will
be equal to an angle from a rectangle.
So, these are the Euclid’s first four postulates
that will help us in having a
better understanding of geometry.
In the next lesson, we will study about the
Euclid’s fifth postulate and move
ahead.